g20 leaders are set to focus on climate
change on the second of their two-day
summit in rome
the day began with a visit to the city's
landmark trevi fountain said to make
wishes come true for those who toss up
in a coin
and the wish list is long with calls
around the globe for action on not just
the environment but also vaccines for
poorer countries and help to restart the
global economy
on the first day of their meetings
leaders reached consensus on one issue
backing a minimum global tax rate of 15
percent for the world's biggest
corporations
thousands have taken to the streets of
the italian capital to demand action on
global warming
the g20 group of industrial nations
assembled here accounts for an estimated
80 percent of global greenhouse gas
emissions
leaders posed for the traditional family
photo alongside frontline emergency
services workers in appreciation of
their efforts during the pandemic
expectations for this meeting and the
key cop 26 conference seem low
they talk like blah blah blah and stuff
but i hope that they will do something
but i don't think so i don't expect that
they will
really
decide something incisive for the future
something that can change it really
for the population for also the people
of the third world
and i think that they are just meeting
for discuss but
they won't change anything we don't
really have any expectations
regarding the
the the outcomes of this meeting germany
it's an emotional occasion for the
german chancellor angela merkel the last
of no less than 17 g20 summits that
she's been to during her time in office
she hasn't missed a single one
of course we are delighted to be able to
be here in person
and it was especially moving at the
family photo to see not just the
political leaders
but also doctors
nurses and paramedics
merkel has brought along her most likely
successor as chancellor olaf schultz
took the opportunity to meet some of his
future fellow heads of government
in the day's business the politicians
backed a 15 global minimum tax on
corporations they considered calls for
faster deliveries of covid19 vaccines to
poorer countries and made some vague
commitments on climate change
and let's cross directly now to dw
correspondent alexandra falnamen in rome
alexander what's on the agenda for today
the climate crisis and how to fight the
climate crisis that is on the agenda
today a very important topic and the
question is of course whether the g20
leaders will be able to agree on
concrete timelines and more ambitious
climate goals and the sticking point
here here is whether they will be able
to set a concrete
date for phasing out coal use and we are
hearing that this is still very
controversial and the negotiators were
talking and trying to
put a draft communique together the
whole night so it's still not clear
whether we are going to see a strong
signal before the uan climate conference
in glasgow starts today
and the agreement on taxing
multinationals seems like a big step
forward when you look at past g20s and
usually they just finish with a
communique will it be the only big
decision do you think
well we'll see this was of course a huge
deal that the g20 leaders agreed on this
first major tax reform in decades what
we are hearing is also that it looks
like they would be able to make good on
their promise to provide 100 billion us
dollars to help poorer nations combat
their climate change and its
consequences so that could be possible
on the sidelines of this g20 meeting
there was another breaking news so to
speak the us and the european union were
able to
put aside their trade dispute with
regards to aluminum and steel
tariffs so the european union will be in
the future able to export aluminum and
steel to the united states tariff free
at least up to certain quarters and
in return it is not going to double down
on tariffs on u.s goods so this is
definitely good news for both sides okay
so it sounds like there's a lot of other
work being done even if the climate
remains the big thing but the
discussions will continue uh let's talk
about germany for a second this is our
chancellor angela merkel's final g20
summit she's been a regular for over a
decade how do the other leaders view her
as she leaves the world stage she's
brought along her likely successor olaf
schultz as you know is there any
nostalgia or anything like that
well i think that of course everyone
here would agree that she is a very
respected and central figure here and
the fact that she arrived here not alone
but together with her likely successor
olaf schultz went down well with our g20
leaders our sources are saying
both of them
met for example the us president joe
biden or other leaders and this is being
seen here as a sign of continuity in
german politics
but also as an excellent example
how a smooth
transition of power
can happen
yeah and i think we can see why dw
correspondent alexandra von naman
reporting from rome thanks so much for
your insights